merci à tous d'avoir répondu présent à
notre invitation avec bernard accoyer
secrétaire général de notre mouvement
bonne année à toutes et à tous d'abord
pour vous pour vos proches
et puis bonne année pour notre famille
politique et puis pour notre candidat
françois fillon
je voudrais je voudrais à l'ouverture de
ce conseil national saluer l'équipe
dirigeante de notre mouvement
bernard accoyer comme je l'indiquais en
étau aujourd'hui le secrétaire général
vous avez vous avez à ses côtés isabelle
le callennec vice présidente vous avez
annie genevard secrétaire général
adjoint notre trésorier national
mais non
daniel fasquelle serra trésorier
populaire quand même un bon ces suspects
mon cher daniel jean françois lamour qui
est le nouveau président de la
commission nationale d'investiture
et puis nous avons souhaité que nous
consacrions ce conseil national vous le
savez une partie notre ordre du jour est
consacré aux investitures aux élections
législatives eh bien nous avons voulu
montrer ce qu'est le nouveau visage des
républicains le visage des républicains
ce sont de jeunes candidats qui se
présentent aux élections législatives
pour défendre nos couleurs qui sont pour
moitié des femmes qui sont des
entrepreneurs qui viennent de la société
civile ils sont ils ils sont ici je
tiens à les saluer je veux remercier
christophe coulon qui est secrétaire
départemental de l'aisne vice président
de la région ile de france candidat aux
législatives dans l'aisne
je me remerciez ludovic fagon qui est
candidat aux élections législatives dans
le doubs
dans la 2e circonscription il est vice
président du conseil départemental
je veux remercier à maintes renouf qui
est conseillère municipale dit rdj du
calvados candidat dans la 2e
circonscription du calvados
je veux remercier notre ami candidate
dans l'indre paulette picard ancienne
présidente de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de l'indre je veux remercier
sarah gentilles qui est candidate en
haute vienne qui est l'adjointe au maire
de nîmes aux je veux remercier georges
suler qui est secrétaire départemental
des républicains dans le bas-rhin et
je vous salue tous et tout au long de la
matinée vous aurez l'occasion de
découvrir ces nouveaux visages qui vont
porter les couleurs des républicains aux
élections législatives
je veux évidemment salué le président du
sénat gérard larcher
merci à toi d'être assidus dès le début
de nos travaux
je veux saluer tous les amis
parlementaires qui sont ici réunis
nombreux membres de la direction du
parti qui auront l'occasion de
s'exprimer tout au long de la matinée
que de chemin parcouru mais chers amis
depuis notre dernier conseil national
que de chemin parcouru avec
l'organisation de cette primaire que je
dois dire certains d'entre nous redoutez
peut-être mais qui s'est avéré un grand
succès démocratique et surtout un grand
succès politique
quel succès quand on a vu je me souviens
là où entendez dire les français ne
s'intéressent plus à la politique
8 millions de téléspectateurs pour nos
débats 4 millions de participants à
notre primaire une qualité de débats je
dois à dire assez remarquable qui a
montré que notre famille politique était
mature elle était capable de se projeter
dans le 21e siècle un monde on est
capable d'assumer des idées on est
capable de débattre
je pense qu'avec ces primaires la droite
française a sans doute fait un bond de
20 ans en avant et bien cela mes chers
amis ça n'aurait pas été possible sans
vous bien sûr il ya eu une organisation
remarquable avec thierry solère que je
tiens à saluer avec anne levade qui a
présidé la haute autorité mais les
chevilles ouvrières de la primaire
les 80 mille petites mains qui ont
organisé les bureaux de vote qui ont
fait les assesseurs qui ont réglé les
petits détails qui en ont fait une
machine de guerre
eh bien ça a d'abord été les cadres les
acteurs les
du temps des républicains ceux d'entre
vous en particulier qui sont représentés
au conseil national
je tenais à vous en remercier et à vous
en féliciter les résultats de cette
primaire sont indiscutables françois
fillon a remporté un immense succès
clair net et notre devoir mes chers amis
à nous le parlement du parti qui
représente toutes les sensibilités qui
représentent la diversité du parti c'est
de nous rassembler derrière lui essaie
de le faire gagner en moins de maires
personne personne ne vous demandera de
renier vos engagements et vos fidélité à
commencer par françois fillon lui-même
simplement tout le monde va vous
demander maintenant de vous rassembler
derrière notre candidat
derrière françois fillon je vous le
disais nous avons montré un beau visage
avec cette primaire nous avons montré
des débats de qualité ça a été possible
bien sûr grâce à notre vainqueur par son
programme audacieux par le succès très
net qu'il a remportés mais ça a été
aussi possible grâce aux autres
candidats permettez moi de saluer ici ce
matin
tout d'abord nicolas sarkozy
je pense
il a été notre président de la
république il a été le président de
notre famille politique il à redresser
dans notre mouvement je pense que le
clin d'oeil chaleureux que vous lui
adressez lui fera du bien
je veux merci pour lui
je voudrais saluer alain juppé alain
juppé restera comme un grand homme
d'état auquel notre famille doit
beaucoup je veux le remercier pour sa
campagne pour le message qu'il a portés
tout au long de ces débats et puis je
veux évidemment remercié les quatre
autres candidats nathalie kosciusko
morizet bruno le maire jean fait
l'équation jean françois copé qui ont
montré que la nouvelle génération des
républicains elle était là elle était
talentueuse elle était capable de
débattre et de servir le pays
voilà mes chers amis où nous en sommes
en ce début de l'année 2017
nous avons notre candidat nous aurons
tout à l'heure nos candidats aux
élections législatives
et bien maintenant il va nous falloir
amplifier la dynamique
il va nous falloir être les ambassadeurs
de notre candidat françois fillon il va
falloir exprimé bien sûr les différentes
sensibilités mais il va falloir d'abord
montrer que nous sommes rassemblés
montrer que nous représentons la force
de l'alternance et m cette force
d'alternance au service de françois
fillon
alors nous allons ouvrir tout de suite
nos travaux par la partie statutaire
vous savez que vous détenez en tant que
membre du conseil national une
prérogative importante une double
prérogatives
celle d'abord de voter le budget de
notre mouvement
je vais donc demandé à daniel fasquelle
de venir nous présenter les comptes les
comptes de l'année 2016 vous faire voter
le budget 2010 est et ensuite nous
voterons vous voterez les comptes de
notre parti daniel c'est à pau
[Applaudissements]